my understanding that the Home Secretary
has banned 84 heat pictures from
entering the UK when the government lead
by example in considering making mr.
Donald Trump yeah
he said I mean he mean what do you mean
I apologize reverence people a religious
commune of them how can I take seriously
any farm policy idea from someone like
him this is the single worst idea that i
have heard from any presidential
candidate ever freedom of religion is a
fundamental constitutional principle
it's a founding principle of this
country I want to talk to the Trump
supporters for a minute I don't know who
you are and I don't know why you like
this guy he's a race-baiting xenophobic
religious bigot
you